[Musique]
oui j'ai faites entrer l'accusé l'
horrible manière hippie punk away we go
t il beau frère un petit côté hugues
aufray il est loin d'être tout le monde
a mené une photo moi par exemple on a
découvert qu'il y avait l'équipe dans
l'équipe le sosie de michel drucker
ouais regardez quand il était jeune
regardez c'est qui ça mokhtari
d'ailleurs sourire ah oui vraiment c'est
pas la même évolution physique alors ils
ont ils sont pas du tout ils s'attaquent
aux chalabrois castany c'est quoi votre
photo alors c'est une photo de moi à la
campagne parce que comme je l'expliquais
et gilles verdez j'étais très proche de
la nature des animaux je suis un petit
peu en petits paysans d'accord
basée à ces notions regarder ces
millions d'années oui c'est vous ça
ouais en fait j'étais beau petit après
j'ai eu un gros moment j'étais moche et
je redeviens pas mal jusqu'à l'avant fin
et votre photo à vous et bars et une
photo je me prend pour une star heger
doit avoir 10 11 ans cette fois c'est
drôle moi ça c'est bénin et il y avait
un truc s'appelait sisters arras cake
ouais c'est aux états unis attention à
toi comment tu te la pètes avec halak la
bnm dont 110 ans en a huit att de sorte
qu'un cap ou pas non mais vous en savez
peut-être avoir un petit amoureux non
non j'avais en amoureux mais c'est ce
qui se passait rien j'ai franchement
ouais allez vous oui bah je sais pas moi
rayon photo mais moi je on n'a pas eu le
même mail de la production a décidé
l'émission ici à 3 4 ont jamais eu comme
gage de passer tout le week-end dans la
fin et j'étais parti j'ai des parties
jusqu'à saint-etienne habillée comme ça
est-ce que même si je m'étais endormi
contre la vitre je bavais et dont j'ai
reçu plein de photos après sur twitter
de moi en train de baver le laval
refaire salle attane à ce week-end alors
oui il s'empare gilles un mois toutes
les photos sont honteuses donc les prix
une à l'école en ce2 où je suis avec mes
plus beaux habits
[Rires]
l'apq ou iphone bah oui certes
normalement c'est monsieur t commence
normalement tu les vois et après tu les
vois dans faites entrer la partie
on n'a pas la photo de sim card sbb en
stock ce qu'il avait lu le bénir garde
la wii abb et c'est le soldat et des
macarons meadows ont déconné c'est quoi
c'est sa très bonne droite
oui absolument mais qu'elles vont
commencer mais tient vraiment à lever
d'hervé nerveux très énervée dit oui
j'ai faites entrer l'accusé l' horrible
21 hippie punk away we go t il beau
frère un petit côté hugues aufray gd
wade serait ma première photo d'identité
est la seule au contraire où j'étais pas
hideuse que j'étais tellement moche
qu'on me faisait baisser la tête
uniquement
on ne voit pas le moins possible et donc
là c'est la seule potable où j'étais moi
j'ai autorisé mais macrez vu quand
j'étais c'est ce soir était super
c'était qu'elle a déjà dit ok tout à
l'arrivée de windows
c'est pour ça oui oui c'est ma soeur m'a
dit c'est l'avion parce que la grève
était en fait quand d'être bouffé les
prêtres comme elle à mon coeur je les
deux mois donc une demande de touristes
n'a pas mon coeur sinon j'aime
l'artichaut parce que j'aime bien on est
fait en effet quelques euros sans accord
du jeu c'est joli alors je n'ai de une
deux mois passe quelque chose qu elle
mais elle représente bien ce que je suis
c'est à dire à la fois le bien-être
l'entretien de soi et la culture dont je
peux vous la montrer
booking dans une boîte de province gp ou
7 mai et yamaska
alors oui c'est intéressant de préciser
pourquoi ce petit match alors c'est ça
masque concombre et brocolis non
organise ces concombres mais non mais tu
avais pas une photo alors la vie celle
ci alors c'était en 1910 qu'à l'époque
la ma famille on faisait pas de photos
franchement donc les photos et dans
notre famille ne faisait pas de photos
ces trois mecs les touffes ou quoi d'où
tous trop moche et en fait il en a que
des on n'a que des photos et
événementiel et la officiel non mais
c'est vrai quoi c'est la première fois
que vous avez ouvert votre point soleil
mais elle date j'avais 11 ans et c'était
ma première communion
alors je revois cette neige série parce
qu'en fait à l'internet on voyait plus
ton zen avant vienne et on dirait une
boussole dirait qu'ils pointent vers le
bas mais sur des signaux en ville et les
noms de la musique non non non hélas la
mèche ce qu'il y avait à l'été les mails
et sébastien et il avait une mèche et je
voulais faire pareil ça accord
maintenant d'y aller passer sur mon
choix j'ai un nom compliqué
[Musique]